Billy Bush has returned to TV to
challenge President Trump who was
reportedly denying that his voices on
that infamous Access Hollywood tape wish
appeared on CBS's Late Show with Stephen
Colbert last night after writing a New
York Times op-ed responding directly to
the president Jericka Duncan is here
with last night's interview jurika good
morning good morning the former Today
Show co-host described hearing his
interaction with mr. Trump on that tape
as a gut punch every time he did not
mince words on colbert echoing the same
charge he made in The Times you can't
say that that is your voice I was there
you were there that's your voice on the
tape pushed back hard on president
Trump's reported denial of the Access
Hollywood tape in the last 14 months of
my life I have been dealing with it you
dealt with it for 14 minutes and went on
to be the president the tape was
released one month before the
presidential election you can do
anything whatever you want grab him by
the then candidate Trump issued a public
apology that same day I said it I was
wrong and I apologized after the tape
surfaced more than a dozen women accused
mr. Trump of sexual misconduct the
president denies all of the accusations
then last month the New York Times
reported that not long after his win
president-elect Trump told a Republican
senator that he wanted to investigate
the recording adding we don't think that
was my voice according to The Times mr.
Trump has continued to suggest that the
tape was not actually him and that
struck a nerve with Bush who says he
believes the women who have accused the
president of wrongdoing you're reopening
wounds on them to enough Sanath Bush
wrote an op-ed titled yes Donald Trump
you said that in it he says there were
seven other guys on the bus at the time
adding every single one of us assumed we
were listening to a crass stand-up act
surely we thought none of this was real
so I think he was just sort of thought
there was a man detailing a sexual
assault strategy to me I would have
called the FBI not just reported it to
my executive producer well Bush says in
2005 when the tape was made mr.
Trump was a big star on NBC's The
Apprentice and quote everybody had to
kiss the ring a little bit of the Donald
because he was making so much money for
NBC viana really put things into
perspective right what a year it has
been and I'm glad he didn't back away
from owning what he says were his own
mistakes as well Jericka thank you